je le vois et j'entends way gad elmaleh
le gad elmaleh le grand gad elmaleh cas
pas monter un meuble
iker venez là la cabine à bluff c'est
très simple vous allez devoir regarder
très discrètement ce qu'il ya dans cette
cabine tous les deux il y en a un des
deux qui va bluffer
à vous de nous dire qu'ils bluffent ya
toujours du gros gros dossiers dans la
cabine à ben la faim et aujourd'hui
servait du très très bien de quoi fixer
rôle ou comment êtes vous allez on y va
dites nous ce que vous voyez arnaud
petite musique des suspects tu y ailles
du budget au pas sur le sur l'émission
ouaya du budget or on regarde le passé
très discrète mais à 0 regarde très
discrètement alors qu'il n'a pas volé sa
là alors c'est alors qu'est ce que vous
avez vu moi j'ai vu là rien bensetti et
voilà et qui ne vit qui font la scène de
la belle clochard avec les lyonnais de
viande et riz kiwi en train de manger
des repas de manger des pâtes ensemble
voilà
on peut regarder lui passait bien ce que
tu as vu
alors on en a tous marre qu'ils bluffent
fait qu'ils ne peuvent pas je peux
regarder où voyez vous dites nous ce que
vous voyez vous je la sens pas du tout
c'est évidemment les deux vont dire
n'importe quoi
comment t'as fait venir jean quelqu'un à
mon frère jean-pierre jet d'eau
moi j'ai vu jean pierre pernaut ouais on
comment s'appelle le truc de benda en
peignoir en peignoir position sur ce
quoi juste c'est le mot peignoir que
vous cherchez quel blazquez bluff nagui
j'ai bien peur nos agents bien perdre ou
s'il vous plaît vous pensez que arnaud
bluff jean luc g jean luc vannier alors
j'y croyais mais après il a dit qu'ils
étaient à poil ça j'y crois pas
ben oui
s'ouvre
au top
qui bluffe est-ce que c'est qu'elle est
ce que c'est arnaud ducret il va avoir
du très très lourd qui va arriver ça lui
il est bien je vais regarder quand même
aussi
shizuku qu'on est très con alors allez-y
du tout ce que vous voulez alors
évidemment d'abord moi je dis sujet oui
bouquet moi et j'ai tout simplement vu
benz
j'ai vu tous les hits de joker alors
j'ai vu tout simplement un insigne avec
quoi une sorte de signe comme ça oui
avec quoi c'est à dire un signe c'est
pourquoi après toi de deviner si c'est
un signe
oies cygnes alors vous questionnez vous
arnaud ducret il a pas besoin
tu n'as pas volé tu l'a pas volé il n'a
pas volé sa là alors qu'est ce que vous
avez vu moi j'ai vu là à l'instant ouais
greg le millionnaire non
greg le millionnaire avec quoi greg le
millénaire à mes chapeaux dan un chapeau
d'aller en slip est aussi prêt c'est pas
un peu beaucoup ça
la crise en syrie j'avais tout tu
trouver un air
il y avait un signe à régler
[Applaudissements]
non les cellules de peau comme ici à
signer le lac des cygnes
voilà lac des cygnes
qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette cabine
à bloc arnaud est ce que vous pouvez
revenir aux téléspectateurs chef et et à
propulsion que vous voyez je le vois
j'entends way gad elmaleh le gad elmaleh
le grand gad elmaleh capable de monter
un meuble
iker alors qu'est ce qu'elle aime ça les
y regarder tous loués arrête tes
conneries
qu'est ce que vous voyez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que moi avoue qu'à du tout et
l'esprit je vois moi je vois je vois ton
oui bah deux secondes je vois tsonga way
avait avec des tombes en bois et qui
sait comme ça et il fait qu'il fait
comme ça il fait est fait à la dallas
alors tu as à votre avis alors
changement garrec des tombes en bois
donc song boire tout bois alors vous
aidera à penser que quatre bluff oui ce
type gie pas il ya des trop gros pied
pour des trucs en voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]